- L'annoe de femmes:
Québec abandonne le test PAP,
le test de détection du canc
du col de l'utérus, pour
le remplacer par un autre,
plus efficace et plus simple
ministre
de la Santé du Québec
- C'est une très, très bonne
décision parce que c'est
beaucoup moins intrusif.
ic qu'on utilise depuis
longtemps pour détecter le virus
du papillome humain, un virun, s
transmissible sexuellement quies
cancers du col de l'utérus.
On l'utilisera maintenant
en première ligne pour le
dépistage systématique de
ce type de canqer.
obstétriciens gynécol. du Canada
- Le fameux dépistage du VPH
met justement d'avoir
un test qui est plus facile à
faire, faut juste faire un
ment avec un Q-tip dans
l'ouverture du col.
Québec mettra sur pied un
véritable programme de dépi9zXVñ
du cancer du col.
Dre JOSIANNE PARÉ, gynécologue
CIUSSS de l'Estrier
comment on est capables de
faire un système un peu
automatisé, donc les femmes
recoivent des invitations,
puis que tout ça soit comme
un peu orchestré avec les
laboratoires, chose qui est
pas faite actuellement
avec la cytologie.
- Le programme de dépistage
viserait les femmes de25 à 65 aa
de passer un test tous
les cinq ans.
Pour ceeulent
se faire tester mais qui n'ont
pas de médecin de famille,
il y aura toujours le guiche
- Je pense que passer par lesere
guichet d'accès va faciliter
l'expérience patient puis c'est
ça qu'on veut pour les femmes.
- On évalue aussi la possibilite
d'autoprélèvement, à la maison,
avec un écouvillon. D'abord auxs
éloignées puis, si ça
fonctionne, à toutes celles
qui le s
Différentes stratégies,
mais le même objectif.
- On veut que le cancer du col
au Québec, au Canada, même
des objectifs que l'OMS s'est
donné dans les prochains
vingt ans, c'est qu'il n'y en
ait plus de cancer du col
chez nos jeunes femmes.
- Au Canada, une femme sur
168 développe un cancer du col
de l'utérus au cours de sa vie.
Ici Normand Grondin,
Radio-Canada, Montréal